these are the ashes of the Amazon it's a
truly unique place and it sucks in and
stores some of the carbon we all produce
but it's under attack like never before
in the space of two months this summer
great swathes of this mighty rainforest
have been wiped out to work out why it
matters you have to get there to a
rainforest that stretches beyond borders
and is a true wilderness and there it is
the natural disaster that just keeps
repeating itself this is quite close to
the border between the state of Rondonia
and a crater the states that have asked
for emergency help you can see what it's
done through here of the course the last
few weeks and we came off the main road
because we saw this huge plume above us
and the area that's burning is perhaps
another mile or so in that direction
it's a long empty walk-in you get closer
you just hear it crackling away it keeps
popping up in different sections
there are trees falling all around us
and this is what deforestation looks
like up close there is nobody here there
is nobody to stop it and it just goes on
for mile after mile
the most biodiverse land on the planet
is being eaten we could track the fires
live through Brazil's Environment Agency
website there are thousands of red hot
spots environmentalists have long warned
that the president of Brazil was laying
the ground for this advocating
responsible exploitation of the
rainforest so people have been setting
fires to create farmland more and more
farmland it's illegal an
environmentalist like Luciana are
dismayed Toki vendo to do a pigeon so
Koho todo Jia nice camera music epgm so
cool what is your impression of how the
Brazilian government are dealing with
this no Toledo governor Brazil arrow now
is tallied and governor Brazil arrow a
haze bosavi breeze there are over a
thousand tributaries that flow into the
great Amazon River
we crossed many of them deeper into
Amazonas State at the end of the highway
where the road just runs out we picked
up Matias it invited us into his home in
the forest
hello mom - yeah yeah Tom Tom
he's indigenous community or not cut off
from the world
oh yeah where's Tom Thomas but it is a
simple village that is protected by the
rainforest not for the first time these
indigenous people are under attack the
party digest something for criminal both
windage okay Conejo out there
Tim Icicle Cherokee miles my pollutant -
they will this isn't good for your
health
the water has become dirtier people have
struggled to breathe
but still the fires are being lit these
felt like the flames of defiance right
by the roadside it's a big one at the
heart of this though is a land grab for
agriculture there's been allegations of
farmers organizing burning days in some
states fires coordinated over whatsapp
here they come
just outside the frontier town of La
Brea we met Neilson this life is all
he's ever known
now had a hurry da da si que you assume
a tomato Amazonia doin posad praça le oh
me too me too me too me too me too me
CAD embrace the disposal police
re-interview the Siskiyou faces matter
so amazin SS endogenous he blames
outsiders who have come into the Amazon
looking to make money part of Milton's
Lando is also charred a neighbor set a
fire two weeks ago and it just got out
of control so how do you tame it across
the border in Bolivia they've seen a
million hectares burn not all of it
rainforest President Evo Morales has
sent in nine hundred teams including
himself no pencil he'll be until Alison
dive into budget or not but unrelenting
Cynthia and I must only did she get any
aid Osama psychopathy to 100 there is
possible
in contrast president bowl scenario in
Brazil he took office in January has
been schooled by the allegation it's
down to him and his policies
he's been attacked at home and abroad
[Music]
so they've mobilized 44,000 troops to
help fight the fires and they brought in
international help mr. Bo's Garris a
Gyarados awards especial ha promote our
America council potential you kiddy been
a fierce supporter at the portal will
not support include was nos vemos in but
while parts of the Amazon have burned
the president has been making jibes
about the French president's wife and
declared that he does not want the cash
that Emmanuel macron and the g7 leaders
have offered
not all of the rainforest has burnt and
the dry season will soon be over but the
parts that have been hit have been
decimated
you can throw money at this but you
can't rebuild the rainforest what has
been lost here is the biodiversity that
lived within it and that has been built
up over centuries it's all gone